-Sadie, thanks for coming back
to the show.
I have to talk
"Stranger Things" with you.
By the way, I think this is --
I mean, it's a lot on you,
from what I've seen, so far,
but I want to get
into all that stuff.
First, you're originally
from Texas, correct?
-Yep.
-But you got your start
on Broadway here
in New York City.
-Yeah.
-That's fantastic.
How did that happen?
-It was never really
supposed to happen.
Yeah, born in a small town
in Texas.
My parents are both teachers
and my dad was also
the high school football coach,
so it was kind of
very much living
in like the
"Friday Night Lights"...
[ Laughter ]
-Wow!
-...Texas Forever,
kind of world.
-Do you have brothers?
-Yeah, I have three
older brothers
and a little sister.
It's a little big family.
-Were they on the football team
and stuff, the brothers?
-The older one,
the two oldest were.
-[Both] Yeah.
-And no one into acting,
in your whole family?
-No, my my brother Mitchell,
who's like closest in age
with me,
we just started acting together
and I think we were like
on our eighth at-home production
of "Wicked" --
[ Laughter ]
-At home?
-Oh, yeah, like two-man show.
[ Laughter ]
He was always Glinda.
I was Elphaba.
[ Laughter ]
-And perform for parties or...?
-No, just like our parents
[ Laughter ]
-Wow!
and that was it.
-I love that.
-And we did everything.
Not just "Wicked,"
like everything.
-Yeah, we were just speaking
about --
-Oh, yeah,
well, that was later on.
-But look at you.
You're Annie.
[ Laughter ]
-Yes.
-How cute is that?
Come on.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Ugh.
-Now, how old are you?
-I think 11 or 10.
Yeah, 10 or 11.
[ Laughter ]
And that was
when I started working
professionally.
-Oh, yes, of course.
-Yes.
-You know,
we were talking about you.
We had Taylor Swift on the show
and we were talking
about her short film
to her song "All Too Well."
-Yes.
-And you're fantastic in it.
-Oh, thank you.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Thank you.
-And Taylor was saying
that she wasn't going
to make it,
if you didn't star in it.
She really wanted you to star
in this film.
Have you known each other?
-No! Like I didn't know
she knew I existed.
[ Laughter ]
And I think, if she would've
asked me to like be a tree
in something,
[ Laughter ]
then I would've said yes
like in a heartbeat.
-Yeah. I want to be a tree
in a Taylor --
[ Laughter ]
-That would be amazing,
of course.
-Taylor, if you're watching,
I'm such a good tree.
-Put them in.
It's your track, yeah.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Is she good, as a director?
-Amazing!
-She is, right?
-Amazing. And this was kind of
like her first time
really directing actors.
And she's --
Obviously, I mean,
she can do anything, so,
she was incredible at it.
-You know, it turns out, though,
it wasn't the first time
that you met Taylor Swift.
-Oh, no.
[ Laughter ]
-I was going to see
if you remembered.
Do you remember this moment
right here?
-Yes!
[ Awws ]
I was so upset
because my eyes were like
halfway closed
and I look like I was like --
I looked like a drunk child.
[ Laughter ]
-No, you did not.
-I left and I was like,
"Oh, I blew it! I blew it!"
-No, you look cute! Wait.
How did you meet Taylor Swift,
though?
[ Laughter ]
Explain this to me.
-That was at her concert.
I like knew someone
who could like
get me into a meet and greet.
-Oh, my gosh.
-It was a big moment.
But I was so upset.
-Yeah, but then, now you --
-Now, yeah, it is.
-Now you know each other.
-It's fine now, yeah.
-Yeah.
Let's talk "Stranger Things,"
okay?
Volume 1, Season 4 premieres
this Friday on Netflix.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-I know, finally!
-I know. Can't wait for it.
-Yeah.
Your character, Max --
what can everyone expect
from the show?
What can you tell us?
-I mean, it's
darker and scarier than ever.
-It is.
-The kids are obviously like
we're a lot more mature now,
so the show has kind of matured
with it, in a way.
And Max, you know,
she's not doing too hot.
You're kind of getting to see
her in like her emo phase a bit.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-And I don't want to say
that was like fun to explore,
but it was like a nice
like challenge.
-Yeah. The early reviews,
people are saying
this might be the best season
of "Stranger Things"
because it's just so well done.
There's a new character.
Explain who this person is.
-[ Sigh ]
That's -- Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-Vecna.
-That is Vecna.
I can't say much about Vecna.
-Okay.
-But --
-Can I ask a question?
-Yes.
-Is this CGI Vecna
[ Laughter ]
or is this a human being?
-So, there's actually like
that's all practical effects,
so like there's an actor
in there.
-There is? Okay, good.
-Yeah.
-I didn't know that.
I was like looking.
-So, yeah, it's all practical.
Like they had someone...
-Wow!
-there.
-Fantastic.
-Like nine hours of prosthetics
or something.
-Is it frightening to act
opposite this thing?
-Yeah, but then --
In the moment, yes,
but then, in between takes,
he'd be like eating
a Chick-fil-A sandwich, so.
[ Laughter ]
Kind of took the magic away.
-Vecna wants a spicy
chicken sandwich, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Get Vecna.
Then, the Internet is kind of
going crazy about --
No one knows what to say
about this,
but this is just
on the Internet.
-[ Clapping ] I'm so close
to the finish line.
Like I have not
spoiled anything.
-"Jimmy Fallon,
don't mess this up for me."
-I'm sprinting to the finish.
[ Laughter ]
-I won't mess this up for you.
But are you --
-I appear...to be...
-Okay. Don't say anything.
Alright, don't.
-in the air.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay, you appear to be
in the air.
Let's just say that, okay.
What was it like filming this?
-It was fun. I had fun.
I'm not scared of heights
or anything, so.
-So you really were in the air?
-I was.
And I was like I don't know.
I was kind of like reenacting.
I was living my like Cathy Rigby
"Peter Pan" fantasy for a bit.
[ Laughter ]
I'm a theater kid.
Like what are you going to do?
Like I had --
-You were doing "Peter Pan"
while up in the wires?
-Yeah, it was just like
a little bit.
[ Laughter ]
-I want to show a clip.
Here's our pal Sadie Sink
in "Stranger Things."
Take a look at this.
[ Laughter ]
-How's your mom holding up?
-She's fine.
I mean, she hates our new place,
which is like...
Yeah. It's terrible,
but she's fine.
-Is she still drinking?
-Like -- Yeah, a little, but...
Well, she's working two jobs,
so it's not easy.
-It must not be easy for you
either with your stepdad gone.
-It's kind of better.
-Are you sleeping better?
-Yeah, fine.
-So no more headaches?
Nightmares?
-Ooh!
Sadie Sink, everybody!
Volume 1 of season 4
of "Stranger Things"
premieres this Friday
on Netflix.
Congrats. Come back whenever.
You know we love you.